émission et s'il est nommé Omar Kamé
constituera un gouvernement d'union
nationale il a le soutien des chits qui
ont démontré hier à quel point il
pouvait peser sur les destinées du pays
en écho des dizaines de milliers de
personnes manifesté aujourd'hui à Damas
régistusbum des dizaines de milliers de
personnes ont défilé aujourd'hui à Damas
brandissant drapeau syrien et portrait
du président Assad une démonstration
organisée par le régime pour dénoncer
les pressions internationales et s
Bachar alAssad qui a fait une brève
apparition du haut de son balcon mais la
Syrie n'en continue pas moins son
redéploiement au Liban pendant toute la
journée les troupes syriennes ont quitté
leur position dans le Nord et autour de
Beyrouth pour se diriger vers la plaine
de la BCA des positions occupées
aussitôt par l'armée
libanaise pendant ce temps le président
libanais é Laou a poursuivi ses
consultations en vue de nommer le
Premier ministre probablement Omar
caramé l'ancien chef du gouvernement
pryrien qui avait dû démissionner il y a
9 jours sous la pression de la rue Omar
caramé devrait former un gouvernement
d'union nationale l'opposition libanaise
elle est toujours à Bruxelles pour
obtenir l'appui de l'Union européenne
nos revendications sont celles d'une
enquête internationale sur l'assassinat
de Monsieur
Hariri le le limogage des chefs des
services de
sécurité au Liban la troisème
revendication c'est s'assurer du repli
non pas partiel mais total de l'armée
syrienne du Liban avant les élections
qui doivent se dérouler au plus tard en
mai des revendications soutenues par
l'Union européenne qui a tenu à rappeler
les quelques principes qui guident sa
politique envers le Liban l'Union
l'Union européenne réitère son soutien
en Liban indépendant souverain et
pleinement démocratique comme vous le
savez bien
lalection ser capit et ce soir la
pression sur la Syrie est encore monté
d'un cran avec cette annonce de W bu
selon laquelle lestats-unis étudient
avec leurs alliés des mesures cas où
Damas refuse de se retirer du
Liban